on se rend bien compte qu'il ovation ne
rime pas forcément avec solutions
solutions aux enjeux du 21e siècle
ça m'a parfois linverse parce qu'il se
trouve que pollution réchauffement
climatique pauvreté inégalités et même
effondrement de la biodiversité sont
tous
intrinsèquement liés donc si au lieu de
parler de l'innovation
on parlait d'autre solution une solution
mathématique par exemple un écran bien
un problème mathématique donc transférée
dans la sphère des objets une solution
technique répond à un problème technique
et donc par définition un problème
humain et animal ou végétal problème de
société
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on considère
au départ que la recherche d'une
nouvelle solution technique contribue au
progrès la société mais aujourd'hui on
se rend bien compte que innover pourquoi
est ce qu'une entreprise innove
aujourd'hui une entreprise innove
aujourd'hui pour être compétitives par
exemple pourquoi est ce qu'elle veux
être compétitive parce qu'elle veut
générer de la croissance
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle choisirait la
croissance parce qu'elle veut rembourser
des emprunts ou les actionnaires et si
on veut avoir une d2 à quel point est-ce
que être compétitif
c'est un outil pour répondre à des
solutions 1 c'est un moyen de répondre à
des soluces de répondre à des problèmes
parfois on peut regarder ce qui se passe
dans la nature
un auteur comme gauthier chapelle ont
prouvé que les malgré tout ce qu'on
pouvait avoir comme image de la loi de
la jungle où la sélection naturelle
l'évolution par sélection naturelle est
en fait en 3,8 milliards d'années
d'évolution
la compétition ne prévaut que dans des
situations où les ressources sont
abondantes situation d'abondance la
règle générale dans des environnements
contraint en source d'énergie ou en
ressources naturelles
c'est plutôt l'entr'aide par instinctif
mais et voilà plutôt que la compétition
d'entre aide si on s'intéresse
maintenant à la croissance la croissance
c'est vraiment un levier évolution dans
la nature on se rend vite compte que il
ya deux types de croissance dans la
nature il ya une croissance qui nous
permet de grandir de mûrir d'être assez
fort et au revoir
transmettre quelque chose que ce soit un
patrimoine génétique ou un savoir faire
ou ne serait ce que pour voir ce se
protéger ou survivre dans un
environnement dans un milieu sans suite
à une deuxième croissance
c'est une croissance qui génère des
excroissances une sur croissance est
elle la plupart du temps ce soit le
cancer ou autre eh ben elle a même
l'obésité par exemple et bien à la mène
à menacer la vie de l'organisme
donc si on s'intéresse à ce qui se passe
dans la nature on voit bien que
compétition et en découler croissance ne
sont pas des leviers de progrès entre
les évolutions dollars vers ce collectif
de l'audace
l'audace et poussé par la peur et par
définition elle est aussi poussé par
l'orgueil
à côté de ça le courage autant pour les
philosophes occidentaux que pour les
samouraïs japonais
il est poussé par la justice l'estimable
que quand il est au service d'autrui
donc finalement quand on veut répondre
aux enjeux du 21e siècle nous attendent
on ce qu'on connaît qui sont assez
complexes
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux parler
d'innovation audacieuses comme par
exemple disrupt et la mobilité comme
hubert ou tesla ou est ce qu'il vaut
mieux parler de solution courageuse de
progrès courageuse oh ben moi j'ai
cette prise de conscience il ya
exactement trois ans venait d'être
diplômés d'écoles d'ingénieurs dont
j'étais à peu près à votre place autre
chose près et rien ne me prédisposait à
ce déclic
parce que concrètement j'avais eu de
bons résultats à l'école j'avais suivi
la voie royale en même temps que suivi
mon rêve d'enfant j'avais fait une école
d'ingénieurs et de designers pourrait
être designer automobile du designer
produit ce que je voulais faire depuis
que j'étais petit et au bout de cinq six
dix ans est temps de parcours comme ça
scolaire peut tracer c'est quand je suis
quand je suis sortie d'école hommes se
retrouvaient diplômés que je me suis
rendu compte qu'en tant qu'ingénieur
j'avais vraiment pas envie que mon temps
mes compétences ses ongles en métal en
mon énergie
et bien soit mis au service du problème
plutôt que de la science en tant que que
designer j'avais pas envie de passer mon
temps à concevoir fabriquer des jouets
pour enfants à l'obsolescence programmée
[Musique]
probablement hors de prix fabriqué à
l'autre bout du monde dans des
conditions devaient pas connaissance à
priori impossible à recycler et par
exemple ce que vous voyez là derrière
moi c'est un drone à sa fille un petit
drone qui ça apprendre et sa fille et à
l'époque je peux vous dire d'une enquête
et fiable mais quand je me suis rendu
compte de
quand j'ai repris conscience de tout ce
que qu'impliquait cette activité je ne
suis pas possible
en tant qu'homme je voulais plus être au
service agir au service d'un intérêt
l'intérêt d'une minorité mais bien
l'intérêt général que ce soit celui des
pays en voie de développement qui
fabriquent tous ces objets à rendre
possible ces services des laissés pour
compte qu'il n'y en pas accès chez nous
comme ailleurs où de la planète de façon
générale c'est à peu près comme ça que
le se retrouver quasiment par hasard au
sein de l'association call de bengale et
a travaillé pour le lot des clubs
alors je connaissais pas du tout le
projet avant et je découvrais à peu près
tous en même temps
le monde associatif l'économie sociale
et solidaire la bretagne mais aussi le
bangladesh ses passages
et puis surtout le mot low tech que je
n'avais jamais entendu pendant mon
parcours d'ingénieur parler à peu près
tout le temps plutôt d' high tech alors
qu'est ce que c'est que la low tech
si ce n'est l'opposé de l'high tech
c'est à dire un truc à priori pas super
sexy dans le société dans laquelle on
évolue et bien tenez vous bien parce que
la low tech pour moi c'est des solutions
courageuses et non pas des innovations
audacieuses
déjà quand on parle de los teques on
parle de solutions low tech plus que
d'innovation low tech et ses solutions
techniques qu'on appelle los teques
elles sont d'abord simple le plus simple
possible
certes contrairement aux high tech
ensuite elles sont utiles
concrètement elles répondent à des
nécessités plutôt qu'à des besoins
artificiels
ensuite elles sont évidemment durable au
sens où elles sont le plus économe
possible en ressources et en énergie
le plus robuste possible plus répara
possible modulaire etc etc
adaptable à différents contextes et
enfin elles sont accessibles et
accessible pour nous ça veut dire à la
fois libre de droit donc pas de brevet
ya pas deux elles sont en open source
mais aussi accessible en termes de
savoir faire avec la simplicité
elles doivent être faciles à fabriquer
facile à réparer façon générale elles
augmentent ce qu'on appelle la
résilience de l'utilisateur ou de son
fabricant
pour ceux qui le savent peut-être l'ôter
clab aînés des premières expéditions de
corentin de chatelperron à bord de
bateaux fabriqué en composites fibre
naturelle de but au bangladesh comme
goldberg et que vous voyez là mais
aujourd'hui au low tech lab ce qu'on
fait c'est deliessche et des solutions
techniques los teques partout dans le
monde les expérimenter les tester on
évalue la pertinence dans différents
contextes les documenter et les partager
en ligne en open source pour notre site
los teques la morgue il s'agit d'une
expédition en bateau mais de quatre
projets d'exploration distincts le
premier set nomades des mers un
catamaran qui parcourt les pays de la
ceinture tropicale à la recherche de los
teques l'inventeur de los teques qui
reproduit ces techno qui les intègre au
bateau qui les teste qui documentent qui
en fait des tutoriels en ligne et qui au
passage réalise une série télé avec arte
pour
sensibiliser et faire connaître ces
systèmes le deuxième projet low tech
fort et fuji s'intéresse à comment les
los teques peuvent répondre aux besoins
des migrants et créer du lien social
dans les camps de réfugiés après avoir
travaillé enfin travailler directement
avec les associations locales et ils ont
notamment créé un make-up space sur
place
le troisième projet du lot des clubs
aujourd'hui intègre ensuite de projets
en quête d'un habitat durable ont
commencé par faire un tour de france de
l'eau tech parce que oui on a aussi en
france puis une experte en civilisation
est aujourd'hui l'équipe s'apprête à
vivre en immersion dans un micro
habitent à los teques pendant six mois
pour voir ce que c'est que la vinothèque
documenter les réductions de
consommation d'eau d'électricité
réduction de facture l'impact
environnemental d'un mode de vie comme
celui là et au passage réalisés doivent
série pour à nouveau sensibiliser et
documenter la ville au tec donc règle
dans ces trois projets ou vous donner
des exemples
au travers de ces trois projets au sein
de l'équipe on a pu apprendre à faire
des petites éoliennes à partir de
matériaux de récupération à cultiver de
la spiruline micro algues très riche des
légumes feuilles les champignons ou des
grillons avec très peu d'eau et très peu
de ressources pour répondre aux besoins
d'alimentation
on a appris à utiliser l'énergie solaire
dans un habitat comme celui là pour
chauffer en partie l'habitat réduire la
consommation de chauffage 1 rayures
chauffage chauffer l'eau chauffée ces
aliments mais juge le four solaire mais
aussi fabriquer des réchauds économie de
poids pour éviter que les migrants par
exemple nous coupe les olivier qui les
entoure pour se chauffer au pour cuire
leurs aliments
moi je porte le quatrième et dernier
projet du lot et club s'appelle le
projet a gagné travers du projet agami
on s'intéresse aux matériaux los teques
et à la mobilité au tec et dans les
matériaux c'est assez simple on valorise
les déchets locaux des ressources
naturelles renouvelables locales
pour ce qui est de la mobilité il faut
pas imaginer que c'est la voiture
électrique autonome quand on entend un
peu partout parler c'est avant tout un
enjeu de mobilité utile voire utilitaire
qui répondent à des besoins de
déplacements et transports et nous on
s'intéresse à comment réduire l'impact
en remplaçant les matériaux qu'ils
utilisent aujourd'hui avec ce
constructeur qui s'appelle karenjy à
madagascar et bien un véhicule comme
celui-là simple dépouillée de diverses
options fabriqués localement
à part son moteur et sa chaîne de
transmission par une petite usine locale
et et qui emploie 80 personnes en
réinsertion
nous on cherche à en réduire l'impact en
remplaçant les composites fibre
synthétique par des matériaux 100% bio
sourcées ou à partir de fibres
naturelles toujours de jute et de
bioplastiques par exemple montré aussi
la question du carburant très vite et de
comment est ce que au lieu de au lieu de
passer à l'électrique ce qui a souvent
un impact écologique juste déplacées ont
résolu pas le problème ou déclare on le
déplace eh ben on peut le faire tourner
localement avec des déchets plastiques
sont transformées en carburant par
pyrolyse ou avec des déchets à école
transformée en biocarburants donc cette
démarche là sa démarche potec amant et
vous l'aurez compris au sein du los
teques lab
on est beaucoup d'ingénieurs pourquoi
parce que le coeur de métier lot des
clubs
on n'est pas que des ingénieurs mais le
coeur du métier de vedettes lab relève
du travail de l'ingénieur soit du
sourcing de l'ex terry mentation la
documentation de solutions pour les
diffuser ou l'inspiration qu'on peut
donner au travers de ce qu'on fait
allemand je pense que la low tech elle
pose la question du rôle de l'ingénieur
de l'éthique de l'ingénieur eux n'ont
pas contribué à innovations audacieuses
mais contribuer à un progrès courageuse
elle montre qu'il est possible d'avoir
un autre développement technique que
celui dont on entend parler tout le
temps
aujourd'hui et elle offre la possibilité
à l'ingénieur d'en être l'un des
maillons essentiels autant que le
chercheur l'artisan ou le paysan parce
que ce qui reste à inventer
c'est non pas la technique de demain qui
existe déjà elle est partout il y en a
beaucoup
solution mais le modèle qui va autour un
modèle probablement basé sur l'économie
circulaire et ont pleuré employés
réparer recyclé l'économie de
fonctionnalité
c'est à dire des services robuste et
mutualisé plutôt que des produits
jetables l'économie de contribution
comme le logiciel libre en version
technique donc des centres de création
et de réparation complètement
redistribuées à la fois autonome et
interdépendants et d'économie
régénérative qui ne cherchent pas à
extraire tout de son environnement pour
pouvoir se développer mais justement à
le réparer et y contribuer ou dans ce
développement
eh ben je pense que la low tech pour
l'ingénieur elle représente une
opportunité une chance un opportunité à
saisir d'être peut-être plus courageux
qu'ambitieux qu'audacieux par an
pour n'ont pas apporté la troisième
révolution industrielle avec tout son
lot de numérique et d'énergie
renouvelable qui finalement ne font
souvent que déplacer le problème
autre lieu de production et de
fabrication d'extraction des matériaux
dont ils ont besoin
mais plutôt une révolution los teques
une industrie non pas 4.0 ou 5.0 mais il
industrie ou un modèle de société zéro
déchet zéro émission et 0 inégalités
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]